- Good afternoon.
Welcome to this session
on how to automate code modernization
at Enterprise Scale with Agentic AI.
My name is Elio Damaggio.
I'm a senior manager of a product
in AWS Transform Custom.
Here with me is Morgan, Morgan Lunt.
He's the senior product manager
and main partner in crime for this product
that we're gonna talk about today.
Unfortunately, Shriram wasn't able,
is not able to be with us today.
He's our director. He has a
press event that could not move.
Before we get started,
how many people here
have a problem with tech
debt or modernization?
Okay, okay.
Well, what we're gonna talk about
is that we're gonna talk
about technical debt
in this presentation.
And the challenge that we have
is actually very pervasive.
Everybody that we talk to has this issue.
Morgan is gonna talk a little bit
about how to get started
with AWS transform
and how to perform
transformations at scale,
because transforming and
modernizing a single repo
is more kind of a proof of concept
instead of actually addressing
your tech debt challenge,
which usually spans hundreds
if not thousands of repos.
And after that, we're also
gonna talk about customization
because what every
customer that we talk to
has organization-specific challenges.
Even things that are common,
such as job upgrades,
or Python upgrades or dependency upgrades.
They tend to have specific challenges
that are unique to each organization.
Then we're gonna talk
about value and pricing.
So let's talk about technical debt.
20% of IT budget is currently spent trying
to address technical debt.
There is a lot of resources
that would actually be
spent in innovation,
and that's actually probably
like a lower estimate.
23% of developer time is lost
because there is tech debt.
That is not the time that is
spent to address tech debt,
that is lost because you have tech debt,
dealing with all their
frameworks, dependencies,
trying to figure out what to do.
Accenture estimates $2.4 trillion
of tech debt costs per
year in the US alone.
Of course, tech debt comes in many forms.
There is security and compliance risk.
Your end of life run times.
Many, many, many customers
have Lambda running
on end of life run times
that are gonna be
deprecated this coming year.
But even without Lambda,
you probably are still running
applications on Java 8.
There's lots of stats that many,
many customers are in that situation.
Similar thing for Python and nodes,
you may have vulnerable libraries,
things for which
vulnerabilities are are known
and they're hard to migrate from.
These are usually things that are harder
than just going in a config
file and bump up version.
There's maintenance burden.
You have unsupported framework
that you have to start
supporting yourself.
You may have legacy patterns
that you have to support,
and skill your developers
in these patterns
that you don't really want to use anymore.
There are performance limitations.
You may leave performance
and spend higher operational costs
because you're using older
versions of older libraries
and frameworks and things like that.
You may also miss out on modern features.
Finally, there's strategic misalignment.
Usually what happens is that,
as a result of merger and
acquisitions or just organically,
your different business units and teams
end up using different
versions of tech stacks.
And that is a drag on your innovation.
Now of course, many
companies address tech debt
in a manual way.
Fundamentally, they just treat it as
any other software development.
Their specs, their development,
you track them in your issue tracker
and you just go at it.
There are ways to make things better
and to try to automate.
The existing approaches
are rule-based automation.
Think about ASD grab
open AI tools like that.
They usually require
specialized expertise to run.
They tend to be brittle and inflexible.
You have a rule-based code
modification recipe or rule,
and that works for that specific case.
And if things are different,
there's usually a lot of cleanup
that has to happen after that.
There's usually a lot of startup cost
and it's really hard to
customize them for your case.
They also have a much more limited scope.
There's only so much thing that you can do
with deterministic rules.
In the end, you're
basically writing a program
that modifies a program in
abstract, really, really hard.
There are general purpose coding AI
and there's many of them.
These are usually focused
on an interactive execution.
There's a developer that's using them.
It's an assistant, great acceleration.
They're great products.
They're however less suited
for autonomous execution.
And in the end, we do not want
your developers spending time
to do this kind of modernization.
You want to automate it.
There's also no easy way to
organize reusable knowledge.
Usually what happens
with this modernization,
they affect multiple
teams in a similar way
and with the general purpose coding agent,
every team has to organize the knowledge
to do the modernization by themselves,
and there's no way to share the learnings
across these teams.
Now what we really want is
that we want a low barrier to entry.
We want a tool that's
designed for automation.
We want to be able to learn once
and use in every situation
where that transformation
or modernization challenge happens.
And we want the tool to be
able to improve continually.
So let's look a little
at some of the transformation challenges
that our customer had.
We've had our product in beta
since April of this year,
and we work with many customers internally
and externally to tweak our product
and make sure that we could provide value.
Air Canada here had a
problem with Lambda upgrades.
Node.js 16 was basically
coming end of life
and they had very tight
security deadlines,
to make sure that they got off of that.
They also wanted to migrate
to Graviton instead of X 86.
Internally, our friends at Twitch,
they were still running on
a AWS SDK v1 on their repos.
They had more than 900
repos running on it.
There was an enormous task
to basically upgrade
across all of these repos.
QAD is a manufacturing company.
They wanted to migrate
all of their customers
with each own, with their custom plugin
with their previous platform
to their new platform.
So they wanted to translate
their very specific progress
plugin into their new DSL.
This is a very complex
modernization project
and definitely very organization-specific.
We also work with MongoDB
that is working on how
to help their customers
migrate off of older versions
of the MongoDB SDK and
adopt new functionalities.
Let's take a step back.
In May, we GA'd AWS transform
and supporting modernization
workloads specifically
for VMware migrations,
full stack Windows
modernization and mainframe.
Yesterday we launched
AWS Transform Custom.
This is a product that allows you
to transform any code pattern.
It has built-in transformations
or you can create your own.
It supports diverse scenarios
like version upgrades
and runtime up to
language transformations.
It does have continual
learning and improves,
and it scales transformations
to enterprise wide scale.
What are the main components
of AWS Transform Custom?
You can define transformations
with natural language.
You do not need specialized expertise.
You have natural language prompts.
You can provide code samples
of what you want to do,
migration guides, documentations,
whatever you have.
Then you can execute them at scale,
either through a command line,
interactive or integrated
in your CI/CD pipelines.
We support multiple ways
to integrate it into your own flows,
using your own environments.
And of course it enables
campaigns across multiple repos.
Finally, and very importantly,
it learns from developer feedback.
So when your developers
are modernizing your repos
and they provide feedback to the agent,
that feedback is captured and reused
for the different executions.
Not only that, also the agent learns
by applying the same transformation over
and over on your repos.
So if it tries an avenue of transformation
and finds out that test doesn't work
and doesn't work out, it will
not try that again later.
Of course, all of this
learning can be controlled
and access controlled
and the idea is that you can
define a transformation once
and reuse it across many, many teams
and many repos.
That is different than just
reusing a migration guide,
or every team interactively
using coding agents.
We also provide
AWS-managed transformations
for very common scenarios.
Java runtime upgrade,
Python runtime upgrade,
node runtime upgrades, AWS-SDK upgrades.
And we also have a few
of early access ones,
tech debt analysis and
x86 to Graviton for Java.
These transformations are zero set up.
We validate them on very,
very wide benchmark suites
and we're continuously growing
the number of transformations
that we provide natively.
We also, and importantly,
allow you to build your own
the common use cases where
we see this being very,
very useful are API and service migration,
of course, language upgrades for things
that we don't support, framework upgrades,
code refactoring, custom
patterns and things like that.
The idea here is that you can create,
you can instruct the agent
to execute the patterns
that are unique to your organization.
At the end of the beta,
Air Canada was able to
achieve 90% efficacy rate
for the conversion of
thousands of Lambda code bases
and 80% reduction in
expected time and cost.
And they're basically
are making this product
part of their operational,
part of their internal standard.
QAD was able to enable projects
that would take two week into projects
that took just three days,
achieving 60% to 70% production gains,
and saving an estimated 7,500
developer hours annually.
This is to convert all of their customers
to their new platform.
Twitch achieved the 70% acceleration
on each application migration.
For 913 repos they're projecting savings
of nearly 11 developer years.
Finally, MongoDB was able
to demonstrate a big impact
in modernizing and
migrating Java applications,
specifically for the MongoDB APIs.
Now, I'm gonna give it to Morgan
to tell you how you can get started
with AWS Transform custom right away.
- Thanks Elio.
So the team that built Transform Custom
was very deeply involved
in the initial AWS transform release
and in the release of Q developer.
And we learned some lessons along the way.
One thing we learned was
that onboarding on those services
was harder than it had to be.
So some of them required
Identity Center set up
in connection of your federated
identity provider to AWS,
which had all sorts of security approvals
that would need to go through.
You can get started with
builder ID for Q developer,
but then there wasn't a good way
to graduate up to an
enterprise subscription.
So we tried to do away with all of that
as much as we could with Transform custom
and really cut to the bone,
the bare minimum needed
to set this thing up.
So there is no human identity.
It's all I am permissions,
just like any other AWS service,
meant to be machine-driven.
Of course humans can use it as well.
And I'll show you how to
set that up in a moment.
Standard AWS infrastructure,
security, access control,
stuff that you already know how to use.
We're not trying to
reinvent the wheel here.
The setup is quick and easy
and I'll show it to you in a sec.
It's like literally a
one-line batch script
to pull down our installation
script and execute it.
And then you configure your permissions
just like you do with the AWS CLI
It's worked with your build system,
with your existing tools.
The transformation execution
is happening locally on your device.
So you don't have to like try
and recreate your
complex build environment
in the cloud if, like,
some other services would have you do.
And it's super easy to compose this
as a part of your broader
modernization workflow.
So you can write a script
to pull down your code
from wherever it is,
execute transformation,
push it wherever it needs
to go, wherever you want.
It's meant to be composable, flexible,
an engine that you can stake
and put in the car that
you're trying to drive.
So I said it's easy to install.
That's it, that's the command.
You can go find it on our docs page
that pulls down the package,
executes it, installs it.
We have two dependencies.
You need to have no JS installed
and you need to have get installed,
and that's about it.
And it works on Linux, Mac OS
and on Windows through WSL.
No native Windows supported this time,
we're working on it.
So this command line has
human interactive mode
as well as a machine drivable mode.
So in human mode you have a
friendly conversational agent
that asks you, "Hey, what is it that
that you want to transform?"
It'll query our registry
to find is there an
existing transformation
that does this or am I gonna help the user
to build a new one?
And it has all of our best
practices encoded in it.
So when you're trying to
create a new transformation,
you don't really know what
you need to provide the agent.
Like you wanna go from API A to API B,
the agent's gonna extract from you.
Like, well, if you have documentation
for those APIs, that would be helpful.
Or if you have a migration guide,
maybe you wrote for human users,
that would be helpful too.
Based on our, our several
months of beta we've run here,
we've come to some really
crystallized best practices
and we put that right to
guide you the right way.
As I mentioned, the command line
can be also driven machine mode
with a totally deterministic syntax.
So you put all the arguments
up front and you hit go,
and it's gonna execute
your transformation.
No human involvement needed at all.
The benefits to this
is it's quick to start,
it's quick to start getting feedback.
It's quick to figure out if
this is gonna work for you.
And ideally, if it doesn't right away,
transform custom, right?
It's meant for you to tweak it,
for you to add your own customizations.
If you've got
organization-specific requirements
or libraries or dependencies
or coding conventions, you
can teach it to this thing
and it'll remember it and use
it as it transforms your code.
So as Elio mentioned,
we have some out of
the box transformations
that we give you.
Java, python, node runtime upgrades,
AWS SD upgrades for
those languages as well.
Tech debt analysis, which
I think is super cool,
that's something we got
squeezed in at the last minute.
Basically it does like
a complete thorough
documentation of your code.
All of the relationships
between the various functions in there,
data flow diagrams, entity relationships.
Think of it like the most
comprehensive code documentation
you could imagine is what
we try to generate there.
And then we use that
information to distill out
an analysis of tech debt and suggestions
for things you may want to modernize.
There may be libraries in there
that you didn't know how to (indistinct),
or you didn't know were deprecated
and we try to surface that to you.
Now that's early access.
It's not perfect yet.
We're still working on it,
but we're comfortable enough
to give it to y'all to try
out Java x86 to Traviton.
We're seeing really good success
on our benchmarks internally on that.
That one's hopefully gonna
leave early access relatively soon
once we have a little more data.
And of course if you have
to do something beyond this
or in conjunction with
these transformations,
you can build your own,
you can upgrade your Java
and you can replace
library A with library B
or you know, you can stick
these things together
and mix and match to solve the problem
that you're really trying to solve.
- [Attendee] Is there a setup
for providing transformations?
- So there is not an official
community thing set up yet.
It's something we've really talked about.
And when we talk about
transformation definition portability
in a minute we'll come to that.
But one of our tenets
is you spend the time
and effort to build a
custom transformation.
And as far as I'm concerned, that's yours.
You can keep it secret, you
can share it with the world,
you can, that's up to you.
And we try to make these things import
and exportable as we can.
So, let's see how easy
it is to get started.
Oh, do I?
- [Staff] Just press.
- Ah, look at that.
So what you see here is
I put that command in.
I run it, it's installed. That's it.
And now I hit, type ATX,
which is the three-letter
command to kick this thing off.
There's the help menu and
there's our cool askie
art that, that I designed.
So I'm telling the agent,
"Hey, I want to create
a new transformation."
I wanna upgrade my, what am
I doing here, Python repos?
Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
And it's gonna search through our registry
and it's gonna say, Hey,
it looks like there's
an existing transformation built by AWS
out of the box already to do this.
You want to, you wanna use that one?
And I'll say, sure. 'Cause
it's a totally agentic chat.
You just talk to it.
So it's doing some
prerequisite checking here,
making sure GET is initialized on the repo
that I pointed it to.
And finally it's gonna ask me
if I have any special requests.
Like you're at a restaurant
and they're like, Hey, you
know you want the burger,
but do you want onions?
Do you want, you can give it
your extra little special request here,
which it's going to incorporate
during this particular
transformation execution.
And it's off, it's running,
it's doing its thing.
It'll take, you know, 10, 20 minutes
depends on the size of the code,
size of the code base and stuff.
But that's how easy it is to get started,
to install the CLI, to
point it to an existing repo
you have on disc and just
start transforming it.
Scaling up.
So, okay, pretty cool.
I can transform one repo,
but I've got 500 repos
I need to transform.
How do I do that?
So based on our beta experiences
with our customers so far,
we found certain patterns
that seem to work well,
that kind of map to different people
with different jobs within
a large organization.
So first thing you want to do is plan,
figure out, what do you want to transform?
Do you want to upgrade your Java runtime?
Do you wanna migrate from Dropbox to box,
'cause your company signed a new deal?
Did you acquire another business?
And they use, you know, some API provider
and you have a different one
that you use as a standard
and you wanna migrate
their code to use that?
Figure out what it is that
you're trying to transform.
And then you're gonna identify
some representative targets to start with.
So a code base that's not
too simple, not too complex,
something that you feel
like kind of hits the mark
of a good representation of all
of the other code bases
you're gonna have to transform
that are facing the same problem.
And then you try it, you sit down
with our agent like I just showed you.
It tells, it asks you, "What
do you want to transform?"
You tell 'em, "I wanna
go from blah to blah,"
here's some documentation,
here's a how to guide
I wrote for human users,
here's a blog post,
here's the, you know, you
can really feed it any text
that should be helpful.
Code diffs, if you've done
it before in a few repos,
those are really helpful to actually show,
not tell the agent what
you're trying to do.
So you do this, you create
your initial transformation.
And you'll notice here,
this is done by a centralized team.
So one pattern that we found works well,
especially at large companies,
is when there is a kind
of a core central team
in the organization who's responsible
for coding standards and conventions
and practices, they tend to be the ones
who go about creating
these transformations
so they can disseminate them out
to the application owner teams
who are actually going to run them.
So after you've created
your initial transformation,
start a pilot, do it with tens of apps
and you'll start to
collect some data on like,
okay, how long does this take to run?
How good is it? Does it
hit, you know, 70% efficacy?
Does it hit 95% efficacy?
Just depending on the complexity
of what you're trying to do with it.
And you can also get a really good idea of
what it's going to cost here.
So Elio is gonna talk about
pricing in a little bit,
but it's purely pay as you go.
Totally usage-based, no
subscription stuff at all.
So, and it's based on how
much the agent is working.
So a more complex
transformation agent works more,
it's gonna cost a little more.
So through the pilot pays,
you'll collect data on that
and you'll be able to budget,
okay, to do this campaign,
it's it's gonna cost us
roughly this much money.
And then you can start to scale it out.
So I'll talk in a minute
about the push modality
and the pull modality, which
are the two different ways
of doing these sorts of
campaigns that we've seen.
You integrate it with your source control
if you would like to,
and you can monitor and
make sure the progress
is going as you would like.
And then the most exciting
part about all this,
in my opinion, is the learning.
So every time a transformation executes,
our agent goes and checks all of its work,
looks at everything that it did,
and identifies knowledge items,
things that it wishes
it knew at the beginning
of the transformation
that'll make it faster,
better, do what the human
actually intended for it to do.
And it's gonna incorporate
that information
next time it runs.
The benefits of doing this
in a centralized approach,
like we're talking about here,
is that you only have to put in the effort
of defining this transformation one time.
The quality is gonna be consistent.
Everyone across your organization
is gonna have the same
thing done in the same way.
Like, if I were to write a
wiki page telling everyone
in my company, Hey, we're migrating off
this old ticketing API,
you need to use this new ticketing API,
and I send that to a bunch
of application owner teams.
A, getting them to do it,
it's gonna be hard unless,
you know there's a top- down mandate.
But B, there's a decent chance
just because humans are humans,
everyone's gonna interpret the words
in that wiki a little differently,
even if I try to be
really explicit with it.
And they may follow different conventions
and do things differently.
With a centralized transformation approach
where you define once
and you run many times,
you can be confident it's
gonna be done roughly
the same way each time.
And finally, we break down
those knowledge silos.
So if you have a bunch
of individual developers
and a bunch of individual
application teams
that live in different cities
and don't talk to each other a whole lot
as they make discoveries about,
hey, you know, if I use this function,
I could save a lot of work.
And if I use this one, you know,
there's a bunch of
problems and it's annoying
that information today is
gonna be kind of siloed.
But if you do this centralized approach
with the centralized
transformation definition,
these learnings are upstreamed
and they're shared with everyone
and it saves everyone some effort.
So push campaigns versus pull campaigns.
The way I think of a push campaign
is you have this centralized team,
they defined the transformation,
maybe they got to a really good efficacy,
you know, 80-90%.
They're very confident that
this thing works rather well.
They can directly pull down code
that needs to be
transformed, transform it,
and then push a PR to the
application owning-team to review.
This way you're putting less work
on the application-owning team.
They don't actually even have
to install the CLI or or do anything.
They just have a poll request
that they need to go review
and make sure it does
what needs to be done.
This is especially useful for things
with high efficacy.
For things that are a little
more complex or trickier
or you just wanna give the
application-owning team
a little more ownership over,
you can do a poll campaign
where you have a centralized team
still create that consistent
transformation definition
and instruct the individual
application-owning teams,
"Hey, we're running a campaign
to go from blah to
blah, you have to do it.
The deadline is this."
So and so important person
says you gotta do it,
but instead of doing it manually,
here's a command you can just
plug into your command line
after you install the ATX CLI
and run in on your code base.
And it should get you
most of the way there.
It should take most of
this work off of you.
In our experience internally in Amazon,
this has really helped accelerate
internal migration projects
because there's something to be said
for the human nature of,
hey, do something for me,
versus, hey, do something for me
and here's something I made,
I put time and effort
in to help you do it.
So best practice number
one: pilots, pilots, pilots.
You're not gonna know
how well your transformation
works unless you test it.
You're not gonna know
how much it's gonna cost
unless you test it.
You're not gonna find the edge cases
and weird little bugs
and strange behaviors
that your users may run
into unless you attest it.
So highly recommend taking some time,
you know, maybe a couple of days
to create your initial
transformation definition.
Find some really good
immediate representative repos
and run it on those first.
Then refine it, tweak
it, fix those edge cases.
Add, you know, exceptions when needed.
You may need to decompose a
really complex transformation
into multiple steps.
That's perfectly okay.
We have, I've seen customers use a pattern
where they use our CLI syntax
to invoke one transformation
and then immediately invoke
another one right after,
kind of just as easy as one
transformation for a user,
but for the agent, sometimes
it makes things better
if you give it smaller chunks of problem
to focus on at a time.
Learning items, knowledge
items which are discovered
during execution are not
automatically enabled by default.
That's to prevent any sort
of malicious knowledge item
being discovered and
applied to code unwittingly.
So the centralized team
that owns the transformation
is always gonna be able
to take a look at those
and say, okay, the agent thinks
it discovered something smart here
and it's actually not smart.
Let me not not enable that one.
Yeah, and you can measure time and cost
and you can put together
your automation mechanisms
for using this within your organization.
However, you all store
code and do code reviews
and it can slot into that.
It's a really bare bones,
easily build-on-top-of-able CLI.
Script and automation integration.
I touched on most of this already,
but here's an example of how
simple the syntax can be.
I mean, get clone the repo, ATX exec.
N, N is the name of the transformation
that's stored in your registry.
That's been shared across your company.
C is the build command,
which is optional sometimes
for like Python and stuff,
people use like a linter
or something for that.
It's just a way to tell the agent,
"Hey, here's how you check your work."
Like if you run this,
make sure you don't get a thousand errors.
If you did, you probably
did something wrong.
X is non-interactive mode.
So saying don't wait for human input.
Just, you know, go,
sometimes I call it YOLO mode
'cause it means the agent is
not gonna ask for any help.
It's not gonna ask for any approval,
it's just gonna go do the thing.
T is to trust all tools.
You can also configure tool permissions
if there's certain tools you do
or don't want your agent to use
and then it'll run and then you tell it,
okay, push the PR somewhere
and someone will review it.
You can stick this in a container,
you can stick this in a pipeline,
you can stick this in an AWS batch job.
You can stick this on a
laptop in the basement.
I don't particularly care.
However you want to run your,
your modernization campaign
on whatever infrastructure
you wanna run it on,
as long as it's got,
you know, node and GET
and you can get your code
onto it and it's Linux-based
or Mac OS or WSL, you can put it there.
So we, this is intentionally
making it really flexible
for however you like to work.
What else?
Yeah, GitHub actions, GitLab, CLI,
all sorts of places that,
that you can put it.
Obviously first class
integrations would be nice
if we could say, Hey, this already exists
in the GitHub action
or if we had a pre-built
container we can give you
and say go, you know, just use this.
We're getting there.
And then I just also wanted to note
the AWS transform web application.
So if you've used AWS
transform at all in the past,
you may be familiar with
this web application.
This is where our mainframe modernization,
our VMware migration
and our .net modernization
experiences live.
The parts of AWS transform
that shipped a few months ago,
ATX custom is mostly CLI-based,
but it does have some connections
into the web app, namely
campaign management.
So if you are a program
manager or a campaign manager
or just someone whose boss is like,
"Hey, you said you were
running this campaign,
like I want pretty charts
and graphs, how's it going?"
This is the place for that.
So you can set up your campaign,
you can see all the repos
that have been executed
and I think we got a
video for this one, right?
Yeah, look at that.
So I'm a campaign manager,
I'm a program manager.
I go into the web app and I tell it,
"Hey, I need to upgrade
all of my Python Lambdas."
What do I do, huh, is it playing?
Nope.
Ah, yeah, there it goes.
I wanna upgrade all my Python Lambdas.
The web app has full knowledge
of every transformation
that's in the registry.
So the AWS provided ones as well as ones
that people in your
organization may have created.
It's gonna pull down the
relevant transformation.
Whatever. It'll create a campaign.
They'll give a command
that you copy/paste,
you send to your developers, tell them,
"Hey, go put this in
your CLI, execute it."
And as they execute it on their repo,
it's going to save the
results of that execution.
Like did it validate, did
it succeed, did it fail?
And give you that
beautiful UI in the web app
to see all this collective
aggregated data.
And because it is AWS transform,
you've got the agentic chat interface.
You can chat with it about that data.
You can say, "Hey, how many
of these over the last month
validated how many did not?"
Any sort of way you wanna
slice and dice the information,
the agent can help you with that.
Customization.
- Thank you, Morgan.
So we looked at how you can
transform a single repo.
We looked at how you can
scale it to multiple repos.
What ends up happening
is that every customer
that we talk to
really has organization-specific
customizations
that have to done there.
This is why we called the product,
"AWS Transform Custom,"
even for things such as job upgrades.
You have your own target
versions, your own framework,
your own ways that you wanna do things.
So when you have an
AWS-managed transformation,
such as the ones that
come right out of the box,
you actually also still probably need
to add some additional customization,
things about your
organization's specific pattern,
internal libraries, output style.
You may want to have your
own validation criteria,
like a special integration test
or commands that you want the agent to run
to make sure that things
are working properly.
As an example there,
when you're doing like
a Python 3.8 - 3.11,
you may want to add an
internal logging framework
that you want to use.
You may want to have
specific error handling
that how things you want
done in your organizations.
So this customization happens once,
but then the agents
still continues to learn
your organization-specific things
every time that is executed.
So developers that run it interactively
and provide feedback,
or ways that basically the agent finds
that don't work or that do work,
the agent will still continue to learn.
Sometimes though, you
actually do need fully custom,
and we talked about these things.
There's organization frameworks.
Maybe you want to have
your own custom libraries
or proprietary patterns.
You have strategic migrations,
you may want to change your
authentication service,
migrating from Auth0 to
Cognito or vice versa,
going from Splunk to CloudWatch
or vice versa and doing vendor changes.
You may harmonize the
tech stack across merger
and acquisitions or do
architecture changes.
There are multiple ways we,
you can create custom
transformations using AWS transform.
These are like some of the
ways that we usually propose.
One is the prompt and refine.
You can start with a simple prompt.
The agent will ask some questions
about what you want to do.
And basically after you have
a first transformation
definition document,
you can iterate on it
depending on some samples
and your examples.
You can also start with guidelines.
You may have a migration
guide that's already existing.
If you have an internal framework,
you may want to provide API specifications
of the different versions
or very important,
before and after code samples
of how you want things to do.
Finally, you also have a way to have it,
like do it with me,
which is like a way in which you have
like a very simple
transformation definition
and you basically stop the agent
while it's doing it, providing feedback.
Very, very important is references,
before and after examples
and after you're done,
the idea is that you publish
this new transformation definition
on your organization registry
that is associated to your AWS account.
That is kind of,
it can of course be access
controlled through IM.
Let's look at the demo for this.
Okay, there we go.
So here, as Morgan said,
we can start ATX here.
It's already installed.
And let's say that I want
to do something custom
that is not available there.
"I want to add opentelemetry tracing
to my node backend apps."
I mean, this seems to be like
a pretty common modernization thing.
You could, you may also wanna
change between those things.
What the system is gonna do now
is gonna go and look at
all the transformations
that are existing in my registry.
We have a ton, because this
is our own internal account.
But one of the things that I wanna show
is at the beginning is the
list of the AWS-managed ones
with the description and what they are.
So after that, the agent is
basically gonna say, okay,
there's no existing transformation
for adding opentelemetry.
It will help us create a new one.
And it starts asking some question
and say, okay, what kind
of backend do you have?
Are you, are you planning
to use a specific backend
and do you have some existing logging?
What I wanna say, I wanna say, okay,
these are like mostly express
and I want to use AWS X-ray
and do I have any existing,
if I do, I want to remove it.
Okay, this is also the moment
where it will basically ask,
do you have migration guide documentation?
A whole bunch
and an example for doing
like, before and after.
How do I want to do that thing?
For opentelemetry, what I can imagine
is that you probably want to have,
you may have your own specific attributes
that you want to put,
the kind of traces that you want to have,
and probably you want those things
to be consistent across all of the repos.
That would be the moment to
add all of those informations.
Now it's gonna go here
and it's gonna kind of...
Think for a little bit
and, okay, I talked enough
to give it enough time to do something.
This is great.
And he basically said, okay,
this is the first draft
that it came up with.
Add opentelemetry
tracing to such and such.
It has some entry criteria,
it has some implementation steps.
The idea is that this is a TD file.
I you usually run this inside of an ID
so you can basically say, okay,
this is my transformation definition.
You can open it, you
can edit the MD directly
and say, hey, I edited it.
Or you can ask to change something.
There's implementation steps.
And one of the things
that is really important
are the validations and exit criteria.
It says, okay, package.json
has all of these things.
Some of those things may require for you
to customize exactly
what you wanted to test.
You may have some integration tests.
You may have to provide your own way
to actually test x-ray
and integration, for instance.
Or maybe you want to run some
specific integration tests
that are specific to your org.
The idea is that you can look at it
and you can now apply
it and see what happens.
You can review or modify, you
can do anything like that.
One of the things that I already did
is that I used one of this,
one of these transformations earlier
to actually create,
to add telemetry to this node rest API
and I created a diff in this file here.
So what I'm gonna do now,
I'm gonna go and say, okay,
"I want to modify the transformation
to use these samples as references."
Okay? And if the demo are with us,
they're basically going to say, okay,
this is a file.
I'm gonna take it, I'm
gonna add to the demo.
And, and basically what this is doing
is looking at these files
that can be multiple files,
could be APIs
and what it's doing is analyzing,
is creating it and ingesting
it into its own knowledge base.
And it's also going and updating
the transformation definition document
to include the learnings from those files.
Now this is, if you have
things already available,
you can of course run it in interactively
and basically saying,
"Okay, I would like to do...
To basically give feedback directly
when it's running on
a specific code base."
Now this is gonna create a TD,
I'm not gonna wait for it to finish.
After it's finished, you can publish it
and you can run it like
Morgan showed it before.
This can be, here is still like working,
it's adding summaries
and it's doing like a lot of other things.
Now let's say that I have this
thing and we wanna run it.
Let me (indistinct)
this thing a little bit
because this is gonna take some time.
Let's say that I run it on
this specific application
and what we see here, we see
the transformation definition.
It has the entry criteria
and it has a set of validations.
After I run it, what it does,
the system provides a validation summary
given all the validation
criteria that I provided.
So it tells me, okay, this is what I did,
this is what happened.
And the overall status was partial.
It wasn't able to validate everything,
but it tells me why.
Eight out of the ten fully passed,
two criteria were partially met
because I did not give it any information
on how to actually test x-ray.
I wanted to go and see
that things were in X-ray
and of course I didn't give
it any information to do it.
This is really important
if you want to automate
these things at scale
because one of the things
you don't want to do
is for agents to fail silently,
to basically say, okay, I did it.
And then you have stuff
that's not working.
Because then that basically
means that all of the ones
where it tells you
that are completed, you have
to go and recheck everything.
You want to make sure that
that validation is specified
as precisely as you can.
And that will make sure
that you can automate things
and really have the
savings that you can have.
This is the validation summary.
After it's done, a really nice thing,
we do require git in for all
of these transformations.
And if you go here, you see
that it create a different
commits in its own branch.
So you can have every step
that is in your transformation definition,
that is a specific plan
that is being created
to apply the transformation to this thing.
You have a different step
that is committed here
and you can see and review
exactly what happened.
So the the first thing that it does,
which by the way was in the
transformation definition,
was to add all the
packages, as you imagine.
And it created a new JavaScript file
with a tracing
configuration for AWS X-ray.
And this is the common file that is used
by all the applications.
Usually you probably
want to provide something
that is very organization-specific.
You wanna say what it did.
Then it went and said, okay,
these are my route handlers, data access.
Let's look at like data access.
You see here, there's a lot
of things that were added,
from like orders create,
all this green is basically
all the open telemetry spans
that add the various attributes
or order the user ID or the category.
And all of these things
are probably things
that you may take like a
first stab as it proposes,
but you probably want to provide something
that aligns to your own patterns
and organization specific things.
These are the usual
things that are specified
in how do we want to
integrate open telemetry
in our code bases?
You give that to the agent,
you're gonna make sure
that all of the things,
all of the code bases in your organization
follow the same patterns.
You can also instruct it
to detect divergences.
A nice thing here is that you can also,
when we talk about this, okay,
this added, I have my
updated transformation,
I can publish it.
One thing that is really interesting here,
and let me actually start
a different conversation.
The agent knows what are the
things that it's good at.
So if I say something,
"can you transform .NET
applications into Java?"
This is a hard thing
and the thing is that you
want the agent to know
the thing that it knows how to do.
It will basically tell
you that, well, okay,
this is a very high
complexity transformation
due to the significant differences.
So you can still try to do it
and it will basically tell you
what kind of things you can,
you should think about when
you want to do those things.
If you wanna separate it
between extracting specifications
if you want to use strangler fig,
but basically it knows the
things that are easier or not.
Now let's go back here
and let me go back here to my PowerPoint.
Here we go.
So what we have here,
that was, the opentelemetry
is a code refactoring,
is one of the transformations
that is one of the sweet
spots that we have.
Code refactoring, library
upgrades, runtime upgrades.
We've been dealing with
those kind of transformations
for the last couple of
years in AWS transform.
And we know that the tool
is designed to do it,
but you will come up with new things.
We've had customers come with us
with very, very strange
things and sometimes
they were able to to be
done very, very quickly
and sometimes they data required
a little bit more complex setups.
How do you improve the
transformation quality?
How should you think about it?
The quality of the result
depends on two things.
One is the complexity
of the transformation,
like .NET to Java are really hard.
The two different languages,
it can be even harder like,
you know, a see to rust,
like it can be really, really hard.
The other thing is the input code base.
You may have a .NET to Java app
that is 800 lines of code,
may be able to do it right away.
But even an easy transformation,
even a Java upgrade applied
to a 5 million lines of code
code base with multiple modules
and tons of dependencies,
it may still struggle.
So we continue to validate
the transformations in our sweet spots.
We have ton of internal
evals on internal code bases
open source, and we always make sure
that we improve that quality.
But you still need to have
some improvement strategies
and there are some of these things
that you can do at definition time.
Providing high quality
documentation and code samples.
Running pilots, super important.
After the pilot you'll
usually tend to have
a lot of before and after
examples of things that you want.
So the agent can really learn
a ton about those things.
You also
test it, continue learning in order
to make it work better.
You can decompose the transformation,
like Morgan was talking about before.
For instance, if you want to
translate across languages,
you can first extract specifications,
then do code generation.
You may decide to decompose
based on functional layers.
Some of our customers said, okay,
let me first migrate the data layer,
then I want to migrate another layer.
So on and so forth.
During refinement, we talked about,
we talked about the pilots.
You want to understand what
kind of results you can have.
And if you're seeing
that you're not getting
the quality that you want,
then is the moment where you
have to reevaluate and say,
okay, this is a really complex transform
let me decompose either the
transform or the targets.
Let's talk about value and pricing.
The customers that we work with
in the last six months
reported three things
that they were really happy about.
On one hand, they were of
course the direct time savings.
It was faster than doing things manually.
It was faster than just
using a general purpose coding agent.
They were able to run it at scale.
The other thing was, it enabled
things that they thought
that they were deprioritizing
because they were too expensive.
The Twitch team was
deprioritizing doing the,
doing the AWS SDK migration for this year
'cause they did not want
to spend 11 dev years.
It seems a lot, but fundamentally
what it says is that,
okay, we're gonna work on a year
for a team with the 11 people.
It's possible, but it's not something
they really want to do.
The other thing that was there
was quality and consistency.
Having consistency across
all those 900 repos
or in case of like Air Canada,
like thousands of lambdas
was really critical.
Most of these things are
driven from centralized teams
and consistency is really important.
They're usually in charge
to make sure that things
are consistent across the code base.
And of course they really
saw continual learning
improve the quality and compounding value.
How do they measure it?
There's of course efficiency.
How fast you did you go,
quality metrics was also important,
how many things had to be reworked.
When we talked about a efficacy rating,
90 plus percent of code bases
for Air Canada did not have
to be touched by anybody.
That code was reviewed
and sent to production.
10% still had to be, you know, tweaked.
But that is like, there's
a very big difference
just taking a PR, testing it
and just flying through your validation,
versus having to tweak and understand
and like figure things out.
And then there's business impact.
There's cost reduction, thinking
these are operating costs.
You may have going to like
more modern frameworks
may actually save you money.
Less resource utilized, better advantages.
Risk reduction you may have,
you are on the latest versions,
more reliability, less security risks,
and of course, strategic enablement.
You want it to be on certain frameworks.
So it's usually a reason.
This is generally available,
it's available in US-East 1 today
and we're gonna add all the
other AWS transform regions.
In Q1, we're in eight regions.
We do have cross-region inference,
but they are geo related.
So North America, North America, Europe
and like things like that.
The pricing is pay as you go,
as Morgans was talking about,
is $0.035 per agent minute.
What's an agent minute?
It is basically how mo...
It's a notion of the amount
of work that the agent takes.
You only pay for active agent work.
So if the agent is
waiting for your code base
to compile on your thing,
you're not paying for anything.
If you're waiting idle
because the user is like
waiting for something,
of course you're not paying anything.
However, multiple agents
may be collaborate
to do your transformation.
So 15 minutes of world clock time
on the service side may actually result
in the charge of 20.
We have some examples there
and that's why we suggest to run pilots
on your own specific
transformations to have an idea.
However, the cost is small enough
that it should not be hard
or prohibitive to try these things.
You can always interrupt.
You're in full control
of how much you spend.
What we suggest you to do
and what I incite you to do, guys,
is that to build confidence
through progressive learning.
This, it's hard to use AI
to do these things autonomously.
It's kind of a step level from
using an agent interactively.
What we suggest to do and
where we seem successful
is basically to start with
things that are simple
and already provided by WS.
One lower risk and high value way
is to start with documentation,
you can learn the workflow.
You have no code changes,
so there's no risk of
like messing anything up.
And you can build
familiarity with the tools.
You can then go on
AWS-managed transformations.
Every customer we talk to have
problems with runtime upgrade
and end of life, and SDK upgrades.
This allows you to learn
the end-to-end workflow,
to experience continual
learning in actions.
Customize this thing, tweaking them
for your own specific organization
and you can start measuring savings
and see what you can get
with this technology.
You can then move on to
simple custom transformations.
Think about logging,
adding open telemetry,
trying to modernize things
from that perspective.
In my experience, every
company that I talk to
has one of those backlogs
hidden in their issue trackers.
And finally, you, you can move on
to more complex custom transformations
in the context of larger modernization,
architectural changes, language changes
and things like that.
So there are some resources here you can
learn about AWS transfer
custom on our website,
there's a hands-on demo.
It's super easy to get
started with the CLI.
No complex setup needed. Runs
on your laptop, basically.
Well, it ran on mine.
I am really happy that you guys chose
to spend your time here with us today.
I'm really looking forward to see
what you guys can build
with this technology
and what kind of
transformations you can do.
Thank you.
(attendees applauding)